the fastest homie move in the game
uh it's definitely gotta be one of them
but you have a paw with the back two
right back one is twelve frames i mean
so yeah we have some uh pretty quick
chroma moves in this game but ladies and
gents here we go top three action first
of three let me hear it in the chat man
who do you guys think is gonna take this
man you guys are two you're talking too
slow man i'm not seeing the chat move
fast enough let's go ladies and saudi
versus israel
all right so down four two now gonna
catch him and this is what what
complaint's been doing really well he's
his timing has been impeccable his
okuzami as you can see there catching
him back rolling and that is gonna be a
chuckle do not attack versus yoshimit to
complain with the first round
this is what you want to see if you're
complaining man you know not an oh my
god the sidewalk right so after ford for
unblock if you sidewalk right it beats
most if not all of jim's options right
from the you can see him doing it again
so early on we're seeing complain really
know what to do versus the gin match up
the question is that rife if he can get
just one round a couple of rounds
together that's all he needs because
he's a very momentum based player
okay so now here we go that has a big
whiff there could have got a launch
i just fought for just using the the
boots
oh that's the float but just finish it
with down four there we go right
gonna bring it back one round a piece is
this the start of the momentum is this
the start of the rafe train i don't have
to call it another race train just a
rave train
oh talking about that big car here this
is definitely going to go to the wall
i wonder why it ops to go for that and
not the um new laser scraper
yeah i wonder yeah i mean
i guess he just prefers the uh the other
other um kind of
yeah
yeah he doesn't like he doesn't like the
flipper some people don't like to focus
this guy definitely actually if i was do
it again oh he could have done it again
but that's the mix up and then uses the
rage drive one of the better race
drivers in the game like i said it has a
couple
high um question probability
yeah and you see once again man this is
something wright's gonna have to adapt
to because every time complaint blocks
the forward four into zen he aside
walking right and shutting down the
options yes he said it definitely is one
of those things where it evades most of
the options um you see that yeah he's
using the homie movie he had to kind of
stop that
yeah nice down four two there we go no
sword combo what is that combo oh my god
doesn't get the last hit at the tail
spin
he's gonna go for the ah nice punish i
reckon if he was just a little bit slow
on that punish a flashlight with the
calm
oh my god no we got the pickup nah that
combo is quite tricky to do
just catches him ducking at the end now
that right there why he ducked he's
probably thought the rage drive was
coming now the first hit of jin's race
drive is high and can be done
you made such a big read then got um
launched for that it's actually lost in
the round that hard read
there you go now oh my god one plus two
let's do it again why not
oh there we go big launch i guess
this is dangerous now because you're
going to be at the wall and you know how
good yoshimitsu's okay on the wall he
flips him over again he knows he's going
to stay down yes again so that's that's
the mix-up we said before this could
potentially be if he gets the right ball
no i don't think so come on one more
he's going to do it the lord harry
complain he sussed it out he knew he was
coming rape has gone for that every
single time
complaint on point that shows that he's
been watching he's probably been
watching the matches he probably got the
stream on and then seeing that one down
three the forgotten move the forbidden
move i i
generally said it before i forgot jin
had that the jabbing to low and right
they scouted it out said you've done
this one too many times and i've been
watching i've been paying attention i've
been doing my homework i handed in the
essay i've done it
like you know yeah no no he definitely
says that man he's been watching he was
in the winner's side so he had a lot of
a lot of opportunity to watch um rife
play in the loser side right when you're
in winners you get more time to kind of
watch the losers lose a bracket action
um and yeah he definitely knew that was
coming stay composed complain um
had no business winning that round
really just great great um composure
once again he's been in tournaments he's
a he's a veteran let's see if rafe can
bring it back he just needs momentum
that's funny
that he was it showed that um complaint
is not sleeping at the world he's
definitely still on alert still there
watching the game and being able to make
these because that little paris it was
clutch because
it would he would have lost right and
it's just clutch that he managed to make
it at that kind of time when the
pressure was on
you know and take that one game
advantage now which is huge now he's
he's a step closer into making it into
that grand finals into getting those
points to get onto that leaderboard
okay he's opted to go for the infinite
azure wall of stage he wanted to go now
he wants to go for pure tekken the
purest form you know filtered water just
pure
nothing
yeah and i think this is a great
decision as you can see the infinite
azure the infinite stage because i mean
those those wall scenarios really mess
rape up and i think that um the wall
damage that jim's gonna get is it's not
worth it you know yeah compared to the
kind of stuff that yoshimitsu can do to
you okay okay go for the hot kick no
respect it doesn't get a proper tail
spin and just runs in easter can't hit
launch with a bit too
antsy there
oh nice setup there gets the tech roll
and just uses the powerpuff complain now
australian race that i can run the
momentum train too can you stop this
yeah we talked about uh wright having a
lot of momentum but what about complain
you know he's someone also that's been
changed very well for life parry is
going to get a full can cans it's so
amazing that he knows the exact um
options to use after he parries like
it's not to think about it on the fly
and do it like that it's not an easy
thing to do
yeah now i've had the pleasure of
playing against eye musician in
tournaments in korea on an infinite
station i'm telling you uh one piece of
advice i was given i was probably i did
very well first for my first time
because everyone loses him the first
time one thing that you have to do
versus yoshi
on an infinite stage is try to stay
mid-range that's what loja said because
he said that if you stay mid-range then
the yoshimitsu won't be able to just go
back to the start would start and you
know recovering their health yeah okay
so you have to you can't back that's too
much if you're too patient because yoshi
mister can start to annoy you yeah
definitely
yeah i can definitely see that as
there's just been an annoying character
double can't hit there no one could
really capitalize after that
nice spin out don't get old uses the
parry but
fortunate for him oh great pickup that's
nice instant while standing paul okay i
see you race oh why you ducking oh my
god he didn't want to get sent to
johanna but it's okay he gets the match
anyway there we go rife his success
ratio for making these guys dark i'm
really impressed like he's been hitting
so many guys with the axe kick and
i guess the threat of the
the hell sweep um into launch is
he he just says up so well like so many
of these guys are ducking in that
situation
yeah but you know what it is it's like
he's definitely scouted him this is what
you're supposed to do but imagine when
you're on offline tournaments when
you're in offline tournaments you you
you watch your opponents you know
they're playing you know that they're
going to be coming up next you say how
let me see how he plays and you're
watching he says this is a tendency this
is what everyone does right so he's been
doing this and yes he's been using a lot
of the hell street he's been using a lot
of it so maybe then he was like you know
what i'm gonna duck because i know he
likes to use hell sweet well no he's
mixing up very well just like you said
definitely definitely um i said the
success ratio is is amazing there like
and it's kind of easy one in a lot of
these um realms in it and it it's it's a
thing that
in that kind of sense scenario and
that's the situation
it also shows that you're in his head
like you're two steps ahead you're a
step ahead of him just like you know
i'm in your head bro i know what you
wanna do i know you're gonna duck you
think this this hell sleep is coming
boom back at the head axe kick what you
saying round loss let's go 1-1
yeah absolutely so what is he going to
do now uh go back to the wall stage
maybe pick a small a small wall stage
here
to um to assert the the the okizami
potential again or is he going to just
go straight to paul i mean his first
reaction so is one one loses finals the
winner of this goes up against ultra
instinct potato in the grand finals
someone should play for because the
winner of this ladies actually missed it
is going to be placing second you will
be in second place for the um online
challenge leaderboard and forget about
walls bro we have flaws in stage
now as well we've got three of them
no need for an elevator there's no need
for elevator hey you just you're
breaking through them
yes yes and we've managed to get the the
world record we're proclaiming the world
record for the quickest break of three
floors eighteen point six seven seconds
let's just get it unofficial before
someone gets really upset it's
unofficial
i've done it in 10.
bro
just like you said he knows when to use
can cans
uses that show showing that you know
okay nice so that is that's even scarier
so you can't really stay on the ground
can you
did he just um
did he just do what i think he did on us
on a sword
wow
pretty cool
she's a cool character
yeah i mean i just realized you've got a
tail does that tend to pull the tail it
is right
wait it's going to be what is it isn't
it is that is that what i think it is
yeah
i haven't noticed that before
you've always said i'm mad absorbing
i feel oh god this is gonna be big
damage you're gonna go down nope okay
keep it oh wait for the dogs you're
there
oh is that gonna put the floor is that
gonna break the floor i think it may
break the floor he's gonna get standing
four tail spin okay no while standing
free
that's not gonna happen such a great
conversion then no this is what this is
what we're talking about character
specialist knowing how to optimize get
the maximum damage there yeah
fight and that's it man he he threw him
out of the power crusher he wasn't able
to break it
nice goes for the um
the the whole saw suit this time doesn't
get parried that was actually deja vu
that same sequence happened in the last
game
but he's going for the paris actually
got hit by the sword sweet
i can't can't duck but no launch what
where was the combo i don't know
everybody gets a second attempt at a
combo right now
yoshi isn't raised needs to be careful
does have access uh-oh
okay i said it you gotta be careful
punish oh no
that is not something that you can do
versus yoshimitsu definitely so for
people that do not know spring kicks can
be launched punished by yoshimisu but
the flash is something that you do not
really want to use against him yeah oh
no miss times is okie and leaves himself
open to get sword swept complain now
back in can he take this round oh my
gosh
again no that is not what you want to do
against yoshimitsu
i was a bit out of range for that hot
kick
okay i guess the punished nice side i'm
gonna watch that wow
not oh you're gonna go to the lecture
okay i like this
they're being very patient now uses the
rage drive
now i like this race just slowing it
down a bit trying to just regain some
position you need to be very careful
because his back is kind of against the
wall but both are backside against the
wall nice patience there and a one two
three
i think he tried to flash in between
that it looked like yeah he got hit
though so it was not not not an option
there from playing complain now here we
go okay use that one for a ford four
using them boots these boots are made
for walking no they're not they make the
kicking
yes brave now he's being a lot more
patient in this in these last couple of
rounds
yeah
i mean okay just gets caught with the
downfall too
okay
all right oh big big weird could have
got a can or something there
oh be careful be careful yoshi with rage
need to be very very careful and just
use his opposites to go for the jab
there
quick and smooth nice and clean
yeah keeps him in check there and
rafe taking that that was um
it was scary at first because he's using
the spring kicks i was thinking is he
flustered because
he's seen that um
complain is ready with the punish so i
didn't want him i was thinking is he an
auto pilot now as he kind of checked out
a bit but not came back regained that
composure
and he's now he's taking the next game
so yeah absolutely this is looking good
here for reif now but the thing is uh
last time
uh last time complained with his
position he picked paul
right so i i don't think that that's the
same situation as it was versus
alternates but i think that going to a
wall stage no floor breaks uh he could
definitely win with the yoshimitsu but
i think now that rafe has checked you've
seen that he's changing timing yes he's
chained up he's being a lot more patient
and that is definitely definitely put um
complaint off because complaint has been
thriving on people being aggressive if
you're aggressive versus yoshi he has so
many options you've got the flash he has
down four two the downfall twos of yoshi
from campaign have been so on point
right so now ray's deciding you know
what i'm gonna play a little bit more
patient two rounds in a row and managed
to take the match but what did he do now
maybe that he's being more patient he
decides to go to poor because malik
malakith who is one of the best players
in europe
he also has two characters aska and paul
and he said to me that like we said to
us actually that he would play asaka
when people are quite aggressive but
when they start to be really patient he
picks paul because paul is a character
that can open you up a lot easier right
moves that can just body you right very
very quickly so is that what it
complains thinking now is he thinking
now that he's playing more patient do i
go to paul oh that is a good question um
but this is this is like last chance
saloon right it's 2-1 so yeah he's going
to be locked and loaded with this so he
needs to really carefully think about it
wow
his old main in tekken tag 2 yoshimitsu
and feng was his main team i remember
playing him on three bars back in the
day in ranked and yes feng is so much
more we're actually saying this before
the streamboxes that complain has a
thing and in season four that character
is so much stronger he is definitely an
underrated character but it doesn't
matter how underrated you are you're
getting count hit by that and wall
stretch
it doesn't matter how highly raised you
are
oh my god that hurt me
what a conversion doesn't get the wall
though but complainers in a very bad
position and needs to get this thing
started up geez oh no oh no this is
looking bad for complain right man you
don't let him get don't let him get
momentum
asleep oh no
he's trying to send him to hell he's
definitely got the momentum right now
oh is this going to be another part no
it's not perfect
nice okay he uses that top but he's just
rayford is just disrespecting just going
for jabs all the time after his frames
[Music]
and again completely oh my god he's
getting flustered he's attacking me he's
not supposed to be attacking and rape
doing a very good job keeping that frame
tight there getting those car hit
launchers i'm not gonna say that again
gets another one
he's like you think you can pick fang
versus me like no bro what are you doing
look at this wraith right now with all
the momentum looking super super easy oh
my gosh that was the wrong combo oh this
could be the start of something but gets
the sidewall flat
okay try to catch some duck in there
oh the classic i knew it was coming the
while standing two into the sabaccy
said you got two shoes i'm going to step
on both of them
get the mustang
okay go to the downfall complain now is
this the moment that he needs it is this
that the round that he needed to catch
that momentum to try and stop rafa have
you got a big car here
yeah
nice good block plus frames
oh gosh we got 10 hits
i always get nervous when i start seeing
10 hits
i get anxiety
oh man he's threading the needle with
that one he gets a side wall splat nice
conversion rave very close to making it
into grand finals here for the master
event spends that rage drive
i mean that rage that's so good as a get
off me tool but he has to make this
comeback clean
but ray once he's like we said he just
looks
unstoppable i think it was going to stop
him
i don't know man because the only person
that can stop him now is ultra instinct
potato because he is going to move into
the grand final set eliminating
complaint from the tournament a great
showing by complaining
from israel really really good showing
but
yes
from